et on passe à présent à notre entretien
du soir avec le député européen
maxorville bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous bonsoir très heureux d'être à
Mayotte bienvenue alors vous êtes
arrivés aujourd'hui vous repartez
dimanche c'est la deuxième fois que vous
venez sur notre territoire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut attendre de votre visite et
quels sont les enjeux autour de votre
venue tout d'abord merci de nous de
m'accueillir ce soir comme vous l'avez
dit ça fait c'est mon deuxième séjour à
Mayotte cette fois-ci en tant que député
européen je suis venu surtout pour
écouter nos élus les élus de Mayotte
échanger avec la population sur les
problématiques qui leur sont chères
emploi éducation
santé on vient d'en entendre parler et
environnement
député européen voit des Outre-mer donc
voit également des maorets et de Mayotte
alors la sécheresse est un phénomène que
vous rencontrez dans votre territoire
d'origine
la Martinique on a l'impression ici que
la situation se dégrade
personne ne trouve de solutions comment
l'Europe peut aider Mayotte à ce niveau
là et bien l'Europe c'est déjà mis en
branle puisque il y a quelques semaines
j'ai été
j'ai rapporté une
proposition pour justement préparer
Mayotte qui a désinstallation à mettre
aux normes et qui pourrait durer assez
longtemps malheureusement en termes
d'assainissement et j'ai proposé de
j'allais dire de d'accélérer la mise en
place d'un assainissement favorable au
Mahorais également le taux de chômage
exceptionnel l'immigration l'insécurité
le manque de soignants autant de
problématiques qui touchent notre
territoire est-ce qu'on entend parler de
Mayotte là-haut bien sûr qu'on entend
parler de Mayotte et nous sommes là pour
ça et notre visite le concrétise comme
dirait mon leader politique pour Mayotte
il y a pas de retard à rattraper il y a
une avance à prendre et c'est le sens de
ma venue c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
Mayotte n'a pas de fatalité du chômage
de la sécurité de l'immigration tout le
monde connaît les problèmes et nous
venons avec des solutions et l'Europe
est très attentive à permettre à Mayotte
de mieux consommer les fruits européens
il y a déjà un premier problème le
Conseil
départemental doit devenir comme les
autres une autorité de gestion pour
gérer les fonds européens de manière la
plus pragmatique possible et de manière
la plus efficace ça c'est déjà première
réponse la deuxième réponse c'est que
tenir compte d'une population et des
problèmes d'insécurité cette opération
nous avons échangé avec le président
du conseil
départemental ce matin il m'a explosé un
petit peu toutes les difficultés
rencontrées et l'approbation son
approbation pour l'opération on bouchou
qui se déroule actuellement et que ok je
souscris complètement mais comme il le
dit fort justement cela ne sera efficace
que si on prend un bras le corps tous
les problèmes annexes et ça je suis
déterminé à l'accompagner dans ce choix
alors vous allez rencontrer d'autres
élus d'ici à dimanche sur quoi vont
porter les échanges et bien comme je
vous ai dit on parlera de toutes les
problématiques quotidiennes qui
concernent les Mahorais aujourd'hui cet
après-midi j'ai une séquence éducation
avec des conseillers départementaux et
des rencontres de adoujani de c'est ça
de Janine trois écoles élémentaires et
maternel où j'ai vu l'exercice de leur
métier dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles mais qui révélait aussi leur
ingénosie ingéniosité à mettre en place
des pratiques pédagogiques innovantes à
faire évoluer des élèves qui sont en
difficulté et surtout comme je l'ai dit
avoir des miracle pédagogique très
enthousiasmant de la fin merci beaucoup
Maxence ville d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci à vous après quatre jours de
grève les services de la préfecture de
mamoudzur ouvriront demain un protocole
d'accord de fin de grève a été signé cet
après-midi entre les salariés et la
direction rappelle que 150 travailleurs
étaient en grève car ils exigeaient
entre autres le départ de sabriani
secrétaire général de la préfecture de
Mayotte arrivée en novembre et jugée
autoritaire il reste en poste mais les
autres revendications ont été obtenues
en écoute Abdou Hamada housseni à ce
sujet c'est le secrétaire général Force
ouvrière et il est au micro de Jaïdi
mallieda et Ivana n'avions